all right overall reaction summer game
Fest we just did that real quick Lord
addict what are your thoughts right
quick on the uh summer game first what's
your reaction I thought the pacing was
extremely well I do think that you know
there was a little bit too much dragged
out sections of it yeah where I could
have felt like it could have been cut
yeah I get it you know I'm sure a lot of
people that made these games love that
exposure but to me some of those games
what was your standouts yeah
that made the shows
no Mortal Kombat for yourself I like the
story of horror combat I don't like the
head-to-head fighting oh okay but I will
watch the cut scenes you'll watch the
custody no no no I'll give you should he
already exit the building salads in the
building and boom show on the building
so uh summer game faster or what are
your thoughts what's your impressions
pretty good so far I would say it's
probably about like seven and a half
eight uh I having Nicholas Cage come up
on stage oh yeah
with some people but certainly other
people in the crowd loved it so I think
it's good score
[Laughter]
one to ten
let's give it an eight give an eight
okay all right I'm giving it eight a
seven coat Eastway more to gameplay
so what's your impressions overall of
the show how we feeling uh first person
games are back yes yeah they look really
good um there was some I don't remember
the names too that look really good yeah
there's like uh there's a lot of Fantasy
games and uh versus Persia was a good
kicker it's a person I forgot about that
that's really good nice take on it more
action and then I was just close to
Nicholas Cage right there right there
with Nicholas so
um overall if you had a good little
rating
oh um I give it an eight give me a good
time you had a good time yeah and your
number one by game that you would say
was your highlight Mortal Kombat that
looks so good it looks so good no doubt
that we got of course risking for the
biscuit my man what's up what's up we
were sitting in the economy tight
Airline seats but it was okay we made it
happen we're taking the point out for
the safety
background boy so what do you think
brother like it's your first summer game
Fest what was your opinion Impressions
oh man he was absolutely
absolutely man for me it wasn't it
wasn't really a game show for me but
there was some good stuff there oh some
good stuff there what was your number
one highlighter 110.
um Mortal Kombat I was sick he's awesome
um Keely was killed Nick cages Nick Cage
is cool yeah so yeah it was amazing but
like amazing but if I did take my b in
here
five six point five okay okay he's a
little two a little long in the tooth
yeah okay okay yeah basic was okay but
yeah yeah what Alex said man like there
was some bits here where they could have
just sort of
moved it along right you gotta risk it I
need my interview all right man so it's
my first one y'all summer game Fest in
the building I was feeling it man I was
feeling it I thought the energy was
great I thought they started off with a
man Mortal Kombat absolutely killed it I
felt oh shout out to yes you're great
that is one of the most underrated NBA
is great by now I love y'all I was so
happy to see you on the screen Prince of
Persia looked great I felt a little
actually oriented super super dope
um I would say like overall it started
high and then I started to fade a little
bit because they obviously had to do
that mobile stuff and all that other
stuff but um I would say overall
probably a seven right now is what I'm
feeling shout out to Sam Lake shout out
to allenway too that looked good there
was a lot of games that looked good oh
Final Fantasy 7 we killed we killed the
show we killed the show surprising not
at the Sony PlayStation showcase what's
that about so it's just like yeah I
don't know man it was crazy we see
Hip-Hop over there we're gonna get him
in here as well too but overall race
show is my first summer game Fest I'm
excited to give y'all this and showing
people I must open it because they
didn't have any Sony that's true
but look we're gonna move it on
Security's gonna get us out of here in a
minute so we gotta move but uh look it's
our first one summer game fast I love
podcast once again yeah we will see
y'all all right